JEREMIAH FOLLIS: Hi,
I'm Jeremiah Follis,
a PMM on Microsoft
Security for AI team.
And, today, we're
talking about how
to make any agent enterprise
ready using Agent 365 SDK.
And I'm joined here
by Sunil Garg,
and he's been leading
the Agent 365 SDK work.
And so, yeah, thanks
for being here, Sunil.
SUNIL GARG: Yeah,
thank you, Jeremiah.
Nice to be here.
Hi, everyone, I am Sunil Garg.
I am a Product Manager
on the Agent 365 team.
I run the Agent 365 SDK and CLI.
And I also am a deployed
PM in our ecosystem
for driving partner adoption.
So I get to spend a lot of time
with developers, and I'm happy
to talk about all of that
today with all of you.
Nice to be here.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: Yeah, so
this session is really
to help developers or security
leaders understand the
importance of observability,
governance, and security
for agents, and what Agent
365 SDK does and what you get
out of integrating with it.
So, yeah, let's go
ahead and dig in.
Sunil, developers everywhere
are building agents
to drive real business and
technology transformation,
but security and risk concerns
can stall adoption fast.
From where you sit, what should
developers focus on to clear
that hurdle, and what's keeping
the enterprise customers
up at night?
SUNIL GARG: And that's
a great question.
And, honestly, it's
the one I get more
than any other right now.
So here is what I would say
to my developer audience.
The excitement around agents
is completely justified.
Eight-two percent of leaders
are planning to deploy agents
in the next 12 to 18
months just to keep
up with the workforce demand.
But that same momentum is
what's creating the anxiety
on the other side of the table.
When I talk to CISOs and CIOs,
four things
consistently come up.
First, agent sprawl
and resource access.
Every team is spinning up agents
and each one needs identity,
permissions, and access
to data and tools.
The most important shift
in your mental model
as a developer is this,
an agent is not an app,
it's an actor with
its own brain.
Give it a scoped identity,
least privilege access,
and an audit trail from day one.
If you bolt on governance later,
you have already lost it.
Second, data oversharing.
Eighty percent of leaders
tell us their top concern is
sensitive data
leaking through AI.
This usually isn't
a model problem,
it's a grounding problem.
The agent has access to, say,
a SharePoint site, a CRM,
an email thread that the
user technically can reach,
but probably shouldn't be
surfacing in this context.
Developers need to design agents
with data boundaries in mind,
agents respecting sensitivity
labels, honoring the permissions
of the user invoking the agent,
and never let the agent become
a shortcut around controls
that already exist
in the enterprise.
Third, the new threat surface.
Eighty-eight percent of
organizations are worried
about indirect prompt
injections, and they should be.
The moment your agent reads
an email, parses a document,
or browses a web page,
untrusted content enters its
reasoning loop.
As developers, our job is
to build the right hooks
and guardrails into our agents
so enterprise security teams
can detect and respond
to these attempted threats.
That's where tools
like Defender plug in.
Assume your agent will be
manipulated and designed
for graceful failure when it is.
And, fourth, regulatory
uncertainty.
More than half of
the leaders I talk
to admit don't fully understand
how AI will be regulated,
the EU sector specific
rules in finance
and healthcare evolving
guidance in the U.S. My advice,
don't wait for the
rules to settle,
build observability
and traceability now.
If you can answer what did
this agent do on whose behalf
with what data and
why, you are ready
for whatever framework lands.
So what's keeping enterprise
customers up at night?
Well, it's not one of these.
It's the compounding risk.
An agent with too much access,
reasoning over untrusted data,
making decisions
no one can audit
in a regulatory environment
that's still being written,
that is the risk.
The good news is every one of
these problems has an answer.
And most of those answers are
things developers control,
which is exactly what I would
love to dig into today.
Look, the developers who win
here aren't the ones shipping
the flashiest agents, they
are the ones building agents
that CISOs will
actually approve.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: Wow.
So that agent as an actor
framing is a big mindset shift.
Walk us through it.
When an enterprise
is bringing an agent
into their organization,
what are the questions
that they're asking?
SUNIL GARG: Yeah, let
me build on that agent
as an actor idea because
it's the frame shift
that unlocks everything else.
So we need to stop
thinking about agents
as features inside an
application, and start thinking
of them as members
of the workforce.
When a new employee
joins your company,
an entire machinery kicks in.
IT provisions a managed
identity, their access is scoped
to their role, their
manager sets expectations,
and everything they
do is auditable.
Nobody calls that
bureaucratic overhead.
That's just how organizations
operate at scale.
Agents need the same treatment.
And the questions enterprise
customers ask maps almost
one-on-one to these
questions they would ask
about any new hire.
Can IT discover and manage them?
Today, mostly no.
Register your agents with an
identity from day one because,
if IT can't see it,
IT can't protect it.
Second, who are they sharing
sensitive information with?
Think about flows of data,
not just permissions
on individual actions.
An agent can have two perfectly
reasonable permissions
on their own, read from
a CRM, send an email,
and the combination still
creates an exfiltration path
designed with the
full flow in mind,
not just the individual action.
Are they behaving properly?
Build in the telemetry,
behavioral signals,
and hooks that let enterprise
security teams monitor
and course correct.
You can't fix what
you can't see.
Are they well
governed and audited?
Every action needs
to be attributable,
which agent on whose behalf
with what data to what outcome.
So my guidance for developers,
the bar for an enterprise-ready
agent isn't whether it works,
it's whether it could
pass an onboarding review
at a Fortune 500.
Identity, behavior, data
handling, auditability,
build to that bar and you are
not just building agents people
will use, you are building
agents enterprise will trust.
And trust is what takes
a demo to production.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: So
that bar, I mean,
passing a Fortune 500
onboarding review is high.
And, honestly, for a developer
just trying to ship an agent,
all of this can
feel overwhelming.
What's your guidance of how does
Microsoft help developers clear
that bar without rebuilding
the security stack themselves?
SUNIL GARG: Yes, you
are spot on, Jeremiah.
It has been a big pain
point for developers
to build enterprise-ready
agents because they may need
to use a variety of open-source
and development tools.
Sometimes they need
to justify, identify,
and patch these
controls themselves,
let alone figuring it out how
customers will eventually use
and benefit from these
bespoke implementations.
So the bottom line is
that it's challenging
to maintain various controls
from different vendors
and make them all
enterprise proofed.
At Microsoft, we really want
to help solve this challenge
for developers to
enable security
and governance controls easily
in the agents they build,
no matter where they build
it, how they build it,
and where they run it.
That's where Agent 365 comes in.
Agent 365 is the control
plane for agents,
built so enterprise customers
can observe, govern,
and secure every agent
in their environment.
We made Agent 365 generally
available on May 1st along
with the SDK, and the SDK is
what makes everything real
for developers.
So, for the rest of the session,
I will focus exactly on that,
how you as a developer
can use the SDK
to make your agent fully
observable, manageable,
and governable by Agent 365.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: So
building on that,
Agent 365 also gives
developers a clear path
to make sure the agents they
build are manageable inside it.
Sunil, when a maker or
a developer is working
in Agent Builder, Copilot
Studio, or Foundry,
what do they need to do
to get Agent 365
controls on their agent?
SUNIL GARG: Well, to be
quite honest, nothing extra.
Agent 365 is natively integrated
out of the box with
these platforms.
It doesn't matter if you are
no-code, low-code or pro-code,
when makers and developers build
on Microsoft AI platforms,
the agent shows up in
Agent 365 automatically.
Identity, observability,
governance,
and security are all wired in.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: So, yeah, I
mean, that's a clean story
for the Microsoft side.
Would like you to flip
it on me, though.
Say I'm a developer building on
a different platform entirely,
how does Agent 365 reach
my agent in that case?
SUNIL GARG: Yep, that's
a good question.
So Agent 365 already
connects directly
to leading third-party
platforms like Vertex AI
and AWS Bedrock, with
more on the way.
Agents built on these
platforms can be registered
in Agent 365 registry through
connected platform integration.
And, remember, registration
is the first step
to solving agent sprawl.
So, once your agent is in
the Agent 365 registry,
customer admins can discover it.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: And what
about developers building
their own agents
with an SDK or framework?
OpenAI's SDK, LangChain,
Claude, custom code.
What if developers'
other capabilities --
what about them rather
than just registration?
That's a huge group and
they need the same things,
observability,
governance, security.
SUNIL GARG: Yeah,
absolutely correct.
So that's exactly where
Agent 365 SDK comes in.
This will be a long answer, but
let's quickly talk through this.
So the first thing I would say
is Agent 365 SDK is not all
or nothing.
Whether you are building with
OpenAI's SDK, LangChain, Claude,
LlamaIndex, the Microsoft Agent
Framework or fully custom code,
you can layer Agent
365 capabilities
onto what you are already
running incrementally.
You pick where to start and
how far you want to go,
which are observability,
governance, and security.
Now, let's start
with observability.
The SDK adds full open
telemetry-based tracing,
which means every input, every
output, every tool call,
every model invocation.
Developers have two
paths from here.
The first, and the one
what we recommend,
is the Microsoft
OpenTelemetry Distro.
It comes with auto
instrumentation for OpenAI,
and LangChain, and
Agent Framework,
plus hooks for everything else.
The second path is direct
injection to an OTel endpoint.
So let's say you already have an
open telemetry pipeline running
or you are on a stack that
our SDK does not support yet,
like Java, for example.
You can plug straight in
and reuse what you
have already built.
And one more thing
on observability,
we have AI-guided setup for
coding agents that wires
up registration and
telemetry for you.
So developers aren't
reading docs and telemet
to get to their first trace.
Now, here is the part
security teams care about.
With observability enabled,
enterprise security teams can
leverage it for threat hunting
in the Microsoft
Defender portal.
The Unified Observability SDK
provided can enable both IT
and security team to
secure and govern agents
with complete visibility.
Next, governance.
Agent 365 SDK can enable a
customer's IT and security teams
to govern tool access,
including access
to Microsoft 365
data through MCPs.
So mail, calendar, OneDrive,
SharePoint, Teams,
they are all reachable
through governed,
admin-controlled auditable,
revocable permissions.
Developers don't have to
build bespoke connectors
or handle consent
flows themselves.
The SDK gives you
the tool surface
and admins decide what your
agent is allowed to touch.
Developers can also bring
their own MCPs and register
with Agent 365 to get the
same controlled access
for all of your MCPs.
And, finally, security.
So this is where Entra
Agent ID comes in.
Developers enable Entra
Agent ID through the SDK.
And, once it's enabled, a whole
set of capabilities light
up for the customer's admins to
configure identity protection,
conditional access,
and ID governance.
So your agent gets a
real verifiable identity
and the admins get to manage it
with the same Entra controls
they are already using
for users.
The shortest way to put it
is bring whatever framework
or model you want, Agent 365
SDK gives you observability,
governance, and security
as incremental capabilities,
not a rewrite.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: So,
once a developer has
integrated the Agent 365 SDK,
where do Entra and
Purview fit in?
SUNIL GARG: Yep,
another great question.
So we touched on some of
this on the last slide,
but let me put it in a
different frame here.
With Entra, there's really
nothing extra to wire up.
Entra Agent ID is part
of the Agent 365 SDK.
So, once the developers have
integrated with the SDK,
identity and access management,
governance, threat hunting
in Defender, all of that just
lights up for the customer.
No additional
plumbing is needed.
For data security and
compliance controls,
including sensitivity labels,
DLP, data lifecycle policies,
all of these works in the M365
surface area, such as Teams,
where the agent is
interacting with users.
Microsoft also provides Purview
APIs that developers can use
to wire the data controls
into agents they are building
for other scenarios.
Regardless, enterprise
customers can configure
and enforce their
own Purview policies
to get it going at runtime.
We are looking into making
this even more easier
from a developer perspective.
So same agent, two extension
paths, one built-in
and one with runtime hook.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: That's awesome.
Well, let's get concrete.
Once my agent is integrated,
what exactly do customers get
across access, data,
and threat protection?
SUNIL GARG: Yeah, so this is
where it all comes together.
And let's take a look at it.
Right? So three pillars,
all built on the security tool
set enterprise customers already
use every day.
Once an agent's integrated, here
is what the security teams get.
First, with Microsoft Entra, the
agent gets assigned an agent ID.
And, from there, the agent
identity can be secured
and governed like any
other identity in the org.
Lifecycle management,
conditional access,
access governance, all the
controls Entra admins already
have and know how to run.
Second, Microsoft Purview.
This is where data security
and compliance comes in.
Enterprise customers can manage
the agent's data security
posture, configure information
protection and DLP,
layer in insider
risk management,
and build compliance control
so the agent meets the
regulatory requirements they are
held to.
And, third, Microsoft Defender.
Security teams can
investigate misconfigurations
or vulnerabilities in agents,
and do advanced hunting right
in the Defender portal.
And, if your agents are
integrated with tools
such as Microsoft 365 apps,
Defender can also detect, block,
and respond to threats,
things like tool misuse.
So the pattern across
all three is the same.
Security teams don't
have to learn new tools.
They work where
they already work.
Let me show you some of this
in action now in the demo.
Here, I have a Genspark agent
that already integrates
with Agent 365 SDK.
And I can show you
the security outcomes
that enterprise customers
can get from this agent.
Let's start with what
every agent needs first,
being known to the enterprise.
Since Genspark already
integrates with Agent 365 SDK,
the agent has Entra Agent
ID and a blueprint,
which makes the agent
show up right here
in the Microsoft 365 Admin
Center visible, inventoried,
and manageable like any
other enterprise asset.
Now, watch what happens the
instant this agent is registered
through a blueprint.
The agent gets a
Microsoft Entra Agent ID,
a real first-class
identity in the tenant.
That means it's
automatically subject
to the same governance the
organization already runs
for human users.
I can see the audit logs of
what the agent has done.
I can see the sign-in logs
to each endpoint the agent
has made or attempted.
Just like how we can
audit for human users,
we can now audit for agents.
Identity governs
who the agent is,
Purview governs what
data it touches.
So every interaction this agent
has, every message it reads,
every file it pulls
from SharePoint,
every email it drafts
automatically flows
through the tenant's
Purview policies.
Sensitivity labels are honored.
Here, I have configured the
highly confidential labeled
documents to only be
shared with human users.
This prevented the agent from
reading the document even
if this document was
created by this agent.
Next, I have a DLP
rule to prevent users
from sharing sensitive
data with AI agents.
We can see that Purview
blocked this message.
Purview enforces it at
the platform layer.
The same controls protecting
humans now protect the agent.
Finally, security.
Defender continuously monitors
the agent's behavior the same
way it monitors any user in the
tenant, anomalous tool calls,
unusual data access patterns,
signs of compromises.
Here, we can see that a high
severity alert was raised
because the user tried a
prompt injection attack.
The rule kicked in and
the tool was blocked.
This functionality is available
to all tools, like MCPs,
that are available on Agent 365,
or you can register your
own MCP with Agent 365.
It works for both.
So, if something goes wrong,
the security team doesn't need a
custom playbook for AI agents.
They use the one
they already have.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: Sunil,
thanks for walking us
through all of that.
Let me wrap this up
for everyone watching.
So here is the picture.
Enterprise customers need
controls to manage agent sprawl,
prevent data leakage, protect
agents against threats,
and meet their
compliance requirements.
That's the bar your customers
are holding you to.
And Agent 365 is what
makes agents meet
that bar whether you're building
on Microsoft AI platforms
or you're integrating an
agent built anywhere else
through Agent 365 SDK.
The bottom line for
developers, well,
that's Agent 365 gives
you a comprehensive way
to make your agent
enterprise-ready
so you can build agents your
customers actually want
and will adopt.
SUNIL GARG: Yeah.
And, just to add to that, right,
from a developer's perspective,
this means you don't have to
choose between shipping fast
and being enterprise
ready, to be quite honest.
The SDK gives you a path
where you can build
on the framework
you already use.
And, the moment you
integrate your agents,
inherits the
identity, governance,
and security capabilities
enterprise customers expect.
So that's what unlocks adoption.
JEREMIAH FOLLIS: Three resources
to help you get building
with Agent 365 SDK.
Please take a look
and save these links.
And we can't wait to
see what you can build.
Thank you for joining us.
SUNIL GARG: Thank you.